[Música]
bebês são bolinhas de amor coragem
curiosidade conexão liberdade absorvem
imensamente e elaboram conhecimentos
cabe aos pais a família a comunidade à
escola e principalmente ao estado
proporcionar que todas as crianças
tenham as mesmas condições de se
desenvolver e as mesmas oportunidades de
vida diz um relatório da unicef
até hoje no brasil na ser menino ou
menina crescer na cidade ou no campo ter
paz unidos ou separados ter mãe com
maior ou menor escolaridade vai
determinar as condições que esta criança
vai ter de nascer crescer e se
desenvolver e é o complemento pertencer
transformar e realizar é imprescindível
investimos nas pessoas começando pelas
crianças na primeira infância que essa
fase muito especial que vai da gestação
até o quinto ano de idade há onde há
maior produção de neurônios e as
ligações às sinapses que trazem a base
da plasticidade cerebral
esta base de plasticidade vai fazer com
que a pessoa tenha condição não apenas
de aprender mas elaborar conhecimento e
tem estrutura pra ter uma vida plena não
ter gravidez precoce na adolescência e
bem na escola tem menos chance de
drogadição menos chance de não ter
trabalho de alcoolismo em geral e é
muito impor tante gente porque se a
gente quer um país com pessoas
socialmente felizes e economicamente
financeiramente também é com o progresso
é muito importante investir nessa paixão
eu nasci menina nomeadamente
em são paulo dos anos 60 filha de mãe
artista plástica e pai arquiteto numa
década em que o ser humano chegava à lua
o movimento hip pregava a paz e amor
todo mundo lutava pela liberdade
liberdade de religião suau racial de
gênero se buscava muito fortemente a
garantia de direitos humanos e tudo isso
era muito efervescente no mundo
já o brasil vive a ilusão da ordem e
progresso da ditadura militar
vim ao mundo com pais atenciosos com
condição cuidadosos e criativos
tive duas irmãs a menor nasceu com a
saúde muito frágil
lembro até hoje do meu pai da minha mãe
na estante pegando a enciclopédia barsa
os mais antigos sabem o que é isso
fazendo uma pelinha ea pondo a cabeceira
do berço sobre esses degraus amarrando
minha irmã com todo cuidado com uma
fraldinha para que elas não se que
aquela não escorregas e se revezando dia
e noite por semanas dando o leitinho com
conta gotas para aquele bebê
lembro também do médico que ia lá em
casa todos os dias duas vezes por dia e
assim foi por semanas
eu tinha quatro anos mas me sentia
fazendo parte junto com a minha irmã do
meio deste plano de cuidar da minha irmã
caçula
hoje eu entendo que essa experiência de
compaixão foi determinante para toda a
minha vida a pequena bolinha de amor que
eu era há uns quatro anos sentia na sua
alma uma primeira grande realização
fazer parte então deste plano de vida
nasceu aí a minha vontade de fazer
medicina
na verdade a minha vontade de ser médica
é verdade eu nasci muito privilegiada
mas mesmo assim avião sombras o que se
diziam para as meninas que se dizia para
as meninas se senta direito fecha as
pernas
se comporta menino tem pinto menina não
tem mata a e só tiveram meninas e sobre
o parto então o médico vai lá e corta
barriga da mãe tirou o bebê de dentro ea
própria explicação foi aterrorizante pra
mim
imagine um bule e um bico de bule por lá
precisa sair uma melancia
as mulheres são muito dizem poder adas o
lugar de mando é muito masculino ea
sociedade é muito preconceituosa
eu tinha uma amiga e tínhamos o jogo
pequena cientista com curiosidade
tratávamos de borboletas formigas tatus
bolinhas flores e até pessoas
um dia eu fui contar muito animada por
uma pessoa que era importante para mim
que eu havia descoberto uma cura para o
câncer o que quero câncer pra mim
naquela época era um desenvolvimento
desordenado de células e que formavam um
volume um tumor
eu também ouvia falar muito sobre soda
cáustica e que era uma coisa muito forte
que corroía os tecidos hora eu pensei os
cânceres que não dá para operar e que
não dá pra tomar remédio porque a gente
não usa uma dose bem certinha de soda
cáustica e ele vai desaparecer
aquela pequena menina de 8 anos de idade
cheia de ilusão ouviu a seguinte
resposta
ora menina tanta gente inteligente no
mundo pensando e você acha que você vai
descobrir a cura do câncer
isso já deve ter acontecido com vocês
as pessoas não fazem isso por mal fazem
às vezes pelo desamor que tiveram por
medo e até por amor mas é muito difícil
ouvir essa questão eu simbólica
simbolicamente naquele momento fui
proibida de pensar e fui proibida de
sonhar mas aquela pequena e tite parecia
já saber que a vida pede coragem
a vida pede coragem e resiliência
aos 17 anos continuava querendo fazer
medicina mas também me encantei pela
arquitetura
fiz vestibular e passei nos dois cursos
o começo da arquitetura foi fascinante e
já o da medicina extremamente frustrante
porque tudo o que eu achava importante
as pessoas achavam bobagem olhar nos
olhos do paciente explicar o que ia
acontecer
cumprimentar deixá lo à vontade na
frente de oito estudantes e de luz de 20
anos que estavam lá olhando tudo né às
vezes as pessoas com as suas intimidades
expostas
isso foi muito frustrante para mim aí eu
parei a medicina antes que a pessoa que
estava a primeira colocada na fila de
espera
pudesse perder o ano então antes do
final do quarto mês ea minha intuição me
dizia que eu deveria fazer arquitetura
ou são sua intuição ou são sempre o seu
coração foi pela arquitetura que eu
conheci o zé alvo era o meu marido
tive dois filhos de coração dois filhos
biológico com quatro netos e estamos
juntos todos esperando a serena a
maternidade pra mim foi muito muito
importante encontrar esse grupo de amor
realizar esse amor com o meu marido e
com a nossa família é é inexplicável ser
mãe trouxe pra mim é um aumento de
dimensão das emoções e uma amiga minha
escreveu muito bonito um dia quando
nasce uma criança que o mundo pare que
tudo passe o infinito chegou e é assim
que eu me sentia e eu estava convivendo
o infinito e fazendo parte de todo o
universo
eu sempre gostei de observar paisagens o
mar as florestas cachoeiras
gostava também de esculturas pinturas
espaços e prédios
na verdade eu até posso dizer que eu
tenho um elo afetivo com o ambiente
construído e principalmente com o
ambiente natural
cuidar do meio ambiente e cuidar da
biosul
era é imprescindível e significa cuidar
não apenas de todos os seres vivos mas
da água do ar e da terra dos minerais e
eu acredito de fato que nós somos sim
responsáveis pelo futuro das próximas
gerações
eu me formei em arquitetura e essa
jornada me levou ao amor e também a
ajudar a organizar um grande hospital
comecei como aprendi naquela pequena
realização pequena grandiosa realização
dos meus quatro anos de idade cuidando
da minha irmã prontinhos de leite mas
cuidadosamente fomos alimentando sonhos
projetos e fazendo cada vez mais
realizações
eu trabalhei muito não foi muito fácil
pelo contrário foi difícil mas eu sempre
achei que estava tratando com equilíbrio
da minha vida profissional e do meu
trabalho
até que um dia eu recebi uma mensagem do
meu filho que dizia assim mãe meus
amigos só tem que dividir a mãe com os
seus irmãos
nós temos que dividir você com todas as
crianças do hospital
isso não é justo ler isso gente mexeu
profundamente com o meu coração e ao
mesmo tempo me deixou feliz porque o meu
filho tinha tido coragem de pôr para
fora sua emoção e conversar comigo foi
muito importante também porque eu achava
que eu era super acolhedor ouvia todo
mundo super flexível e daí eu percebi
que não que eu precisava ter mais
ângulos e mais perspectivas de percepção
e de atuação
eu entrei no hospital em 97 e eu comecei
a não eu desenvolvi um projeto que já
havia sido pensado que era um grande
congresso de especialidades pediátricas
vinham 64 professores de fora do brasil
todos de primeira classe porque o real
estava um pra um pro do dólar
quando o congresso aconteceu foi um su
sucesso científico de público mais sobre
uma conta pro hospital a hospital pagar
de 200 mil reais
naquela época o pequeno príncipe catava
174 mil reais por ano com um único
programa de captação de recursos
eu pensei não é possível vou ter que
trabalhar com marketing e aí fui
convidada para assumir o marketing do
hospital primeiro como coordenadora e
comecei a estruturar um projeto percebi
que o hospital tinha que ser
reapresentado para os seus próprios
colaboradores para os fornecedores para
a comunidade
todo mundo queria o pequeno príncipe
queria os seus filhos no pequeno triste
mas não faziam idéia do grau de
complexidade que acontecia lá nem do
subfinanciamento
eu fico muito feliz de dizer que
daqueles 174 mil que o hospital capita
vá lá nos anos 2000 para agora 2018
nós captamos aproximadamente 50 milhões
de reais por ano
isso é muito importante é um enorme
desafio pra mim saber que todos os dias
a gente acorda com este número na cabeça
só pra fechar as contas do hospital vai
faltar 35 milhões de reais apropriem-se
dos seus desafios de vida os seus
desafios com pessoas com coragem com
curiosidade compaixão com empatia com
conexão elas são imprescindíveis para
você chegar em resultados inesperados
eu sempre digo um chavão mas que é
importante na minha vida não é só um
desafio a ser superado
eu já levei muito não incompreensível ea
minha minha resiliência de transformar
aquela energia numa força para continuar
querendo fazer mais ouvir e compartilhar
é muito importante e eu tenho tido esse
enorme privilégio de conviver com uma
equipe talentosa na área de saúde e nas
áreas complementares que já faziam parte
de um projeto maravilhoso
de excelência e que eu tive então esse
presente de poder me somar eles muitas
coisas nós fomos fazendo juntos e os
anos 2000 foram muito marcantes para mim
porque eu fui convidada pelo ministério
da saúde a participar de um grupo de
humanização no brasil na verdade havia
um programa de humanização que estava
sendo transformado em política e aí eu
por dois anos fiz palestras para
diversos hospitais do norte e nordeste
falando sobre a humanização a
humanização foi exatamente o que tinha
me feito desistir da medicina
talvez por imaturidade ainda eu não
percebia que aqui o do cuidado que
tantas as pessoas falavam que tudo isso
era bobagem
era um diferencial importantíssimo então
vocês vejam que bacana a pequena
cientista
a pessoa que não foi médica a pessoa que
desistiu por causa da humanização foi
disseminado disse humanização pelo
brasil e eu encontrei no hospital um
terreno muito fértil com diversos
projetos implantados ea gente teve a
alegria de fazer muitos outros por
exemplo transformamos o programa de
educação e cultura num setor
este setor mobiliza as escolas de origem
das crianças e todas as crianças a
partir de 15 dias tenham acompanhamento
tem o acompanhamento com professores
maravilhosos
o coordenador do setor foi professor da
minha filha e um dia uma das crianças da
turma que ele coordenava escreveu num
trabalho de poesia fim de tarde vermelho
meu corpo arte eu acredito muito na
importância da saúde mas também da
educação para protagonismo
fizemos também diversos programas para
os colaboradores para reconhecerem o
hospital para se sentirem reconhecidos
mas eu posso dizer que a gente conseguiu
construir uma melhoria contínua de
indicadores econômicos financeiros e de
saúde
e eu quero compartilhar com vocês o mais
importante pra mim
no ano de 2010
faleceram no hospital vou colocar de
outro jeito no ano de 2010 a taxa de
mortalidade do hospital foi dois e meio
por cento muito baixa para um hospital
de alta complexidade que atende 300 mil
atendimentos ambulatoriais e faz 24 mil
internações
mesmo assim foram 500 crianças no ano de
2018 esta taxa foi 0,58 por cento muito
baixa
mesmo assim foram 137 crianças
eu quero o melhor hospital do mundo ea
minha equipe também quer se a gente não
quiser a gente não merece estar lá nós
vamos fazer também um novo projeto que é
o pequeno príncipe norte que é um parque
de ciências da vida com mais dois
hospitais um centro de cultura a
faculdade ou instituto de pesquisas
jardim botânico ambulatório um espaço
pra cuidar e para as pessoas se
desenvolverem
eu admiro demais a academia
os professores são jardineiros de almas
eu não sou nenhuma grande especialista
em coisa nenhuma eu trabalho com paixão
e bom senso e busco envolver pessoas
oferecendo um território de
compartilhamento
eu sou aquela menina de que há uns
quatro anos aprendeu a compaixão com a
família que aos oito anos queria ser a
pequena cientista que aos 17 desistiu da
medicina e descobriu o amor
a profissional que compartilha esse
território de salvar vidas ou de cuidar
tão importante porque nem sempre podemos
salvar
eu sou a filha ea irmã que ajudam um
programa que é maravilhoso um movido por
voluntários
eu sou a pessoa que está aqui hoje
inspirada para compartilhar com vocês
que tudo é possível se a gente tiver
paixão e tiver uma equipe conectada
o que eu queria deixar como mensagem é
que se liga nas pessoas
paixão amor curiosidade empatia
resiliência e ou são sempre o som do seu
coração
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]